you guys movie retrospective time yeah
this is a good one
we would want to do this one for a long
time I'm amazed that this is really well
we've done two Stanley Kubrick movies I
guess we did The Shining with that we
actually did on a regular podcast that
was our first episode and we did a
Clockwork Orange this is uh his last
film Eyes Wide Shut yeah yeah his last
one yeah it's still Kubrick Ian no it's
just kind of it is yeah yeah you know in
its it was kind of a subject when it
came out I was like what what the what
the [ __ ] he doing this [ __ ] for you
know about us about a real sex cult of
real rich people but then you know when
I'm not gonna name his name but you know
child Island man who did not take his
own life when all that [ __ ] went down
and the special island it makes me
wonder like you know was Cooper trying
to tell us something because his
relatives said that that he was that he
was trying to tell us something and
maybe he had heard about things like
this or maybe there's more of it out
there
weird sex cults the thing about it
though is that well for one thing this
movie which I don't know if a lot of
people know this but this movie is
actually based on a novella from the
1920s and it and it actually is even
though the novel is set in Vienna like
at the turn of the century like the turn
of the 20th century it's almost beat for
beat like the plot is almost exactly the
same yeah although it is it's set at
Carnivale rather than Christmas but yeah
other than that it's pretty similar but
still that that just feeds into what I'm
saying though I know this the whole
movie is a lot of plausible deniability
and you could also say that him chosen a
pre-written story is plausible
deniability
although the thing about it it's like I
know that there's like all these it kind
of sucks because I feel like there's all
this stuff that came out like and
there's tons of like videos about this
movie that you know it's almost like
straining credulity like people that
think that the shining is about how he
faked the moon landing and stuff it's
like I was about the Illuminati and all
this other kind of stuff I think this
stuff about the sex cult in there I mean
it does have something to say about
you know the power elites and like the
power dynamic and stuff but I think that
it's incidental because I don't really
think that the movie is about the sex
cult I think it's just kind of like I
think the the significance of the sex
cult is kind of a voyeuristic anonymity
more than anything it's why everyone is
masked and stuff like that so I don't
know if he was saying anything
particular some people out there that
says like oh because Stanley Kubrick
died like shortly before this film came
out like he had finished it kind of but
you know he never really finished
anything because he kept like tinkering
with things several decades after they
were finished and stuff but he did like
have a final cut of it and he showed it
to Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman and then
like a few days later he died of a heart
attack he was 70 so some people have
even gone like the conspiracy theory
around being like oh well he exposed the
thing and they killed him and all this
other style believe it which i think is
really stupid and the thing about it is
like watching it again because I saw
this in the theater when it first came
out in 1999 and I remember being
distinctly like underwhelmed by it I
guess but I saw it like more I saw it a
few more times over the years and I
think I've developed more of an
appreciation for it and like kind of
what it's trying to do and like the
symbolism that it's kind of trying to
get across this is only the second time
I've seen it and the first time like I
said it was yeah I was underwhelmed - I
was like didn't really get it why is
this a big deal yeah and the whole thing
about the orgy is that I think I think
what happened with this was that there
was so much because this movie like had
such a troubled production history it
took so long like to make it because he
kept tweaking it and all this other
stuff you know like he does but this
actually took longer than his normal
films would take and so I do feel like
that and then there was like a big hype
about oh it's gonna be this big orgy
thing so it seemed like that was the
thing everybody was focused on and then
when the movie came out like some people
were like men like the orgies not that
big a deal and everything like that I'm
like well if you watch the movie several
times you understand that like the
orgies not supposed to be a big deal
it's not supposed to be sexy it's not
supposed to be titillating power it's
supposed to be it's just a
supposed to be a representation because
there's other representations into like
with the sex workers and with other
things that are going on during his
journey yeah like through these two days
it's just supposed to be a
representation of the fantasy of
anonymity you know that that is very
alluring but is also ultimately
dangerous and ultimately empty I think
that's kind of what the whole point is
that's only one aspect of it though if
you if you look at the party that they
were at and then later the orgy it there
it does really Lincoln musically and
stylistically with what was happening in
the gold room and in the shining he is
telling you that the ghosts from The
Shining the ghosts of all those evil
rich powerful people that built the
Overlook Hotel are the same people that
are doing this damn sex cult but it's
the same class of people it's the same
type of people that there's a very
powerful wealthy elite and the guy tells
him he says hey you'd be scared if you
if you knew who those people were
you wouldn't be asking so many questions
so it is talking about that yeah but
like I said I don't think that's the
main theme of it I was just one of I
think it's a I think it's just a
mirroring of their individual
relationship because even the book the
original book was about the couple yeah
and was about was about not only the
masks that society wears or stuff that
goes on like underneath that people
don't know about which i think is kind
of what that was but it was also saying
like in a marriage how you know the the
two partners in the marriage never
actually know each other and maybe they
are actually strangers to each other as
well so it was just kind of like a
larger it looks like a microcosm
macrocosm type of thing where it's like
here's like all these wealthy people and
this is what they get up to you know
behind closed doors and then there's the
whole mirroring of the relationship
between Bill and Alice and the movie
where they really don't seem to know
that much about each other's desires or
wants or anything like that because the
whole thing of her like busting out and
telling him about you know the fantasy
that she had about that [ __ ] the
stranger and that was kind of like the
inciting
incident that sends him off on this
whole like journey and everything and
the fact that he hadn't been married to
her for nine years and never knew that
about her was kind of like you know what
I mean so it's almost kind of like they
were strangers to one another even
though they had become you know even
though they were supposedly intimate
with one another and known each other
for such a long time so I think it's
just kind of like several levels of that
like commenting on one another you know
what I'm saying yeah there was a couple
different aspects too there was also a
lot of a lot of references there's that
one there was two references to child
prostitution of daughter pimping out or
a guy pimping out his daughter and
entrapping other people with it that's
in there it Kubrick is definitely
telling us that degenerate [ __ ] is going
on it's a world of horror somebody just
look look at look at look at look at um
that's Tom Cruise whole conundrum is
that everywhere he's turning around his
hose hose and hose there's a big hole
theme and he can't deal with it I don't
really think he's a really good
character I don't really look I think he
did a great job at that character but I
think he's kind of a weak man he's
unlikable so I'm like it actually Tom
Cruise said that about he said he didn't
particularly like that care yeah he's an
unlikable guy but Kubrick is telling us
that yeah there are [ __ ] rich people
abusing [ __ ] and that [ __ ] has since
come out yeah but like I said this goes
back to like when the book was written
like I said there's very similar [ __ ]
right well so it's just kind of like I
don't think it's he wasn't commenting on
anything in particular he was just
saying you know the power elite have
always had this yeah and if you want to
talk about it in in modern times you
don't come out and say it that way you
know I mean you you you you find an old
book about it and you revive it that way
that way you have plausible denial in
1968 he was actually gonna make this
movie after 2001 a Space Oddity to you
he knew the dish he knew this [ __ ] was
going on he was gonna make it up he was
gonna make it after 2001 a Space Odyssey
he initially wanted to make it I haven't
read the novel but he
initially wanted to make the book the
movie more comedic like he wanted to
make low most like a dark comedy type of
thing he wanted a Woody Allen and Mia
Farrow originally then he was thinking
about putting Steve Martin in the role
after the jerk came out so this was
something that he had been working on
for a really really long time I think
like Harvey Keitel and Jennifer Jason
Leigh were in this at some point too but
you know they left some time during
their production because it was taking
so long and Harvey Keitel had creative
differences with them but he but Stanley
Kubrick was very interested in getting
for the central characters he wanted an
actual married couple so when he was
thinking of working on the film he was
like for a time he wanted like Alec
Baldwin and Kim Basinger who were
married at the time but then finally he
got around to getting Tom Cruise and
Nicole Kidman which and they were
married at the time although they
divorced a year or two after this movie
came out and some people speculated that
the stress of the shoot Tom Cruise very
famously developed ulcers during the
shooting because it was like 400 days or
some ridiculous they had only said that
he said it was gonna take six months and
it ended up taking more than a year like
to shoot the movie just because he has
to do like 50 bajillion takes of
everything because he's a perfectionist
but there was also some talk that
because of like all the emotional [ __ ]
that was going on like between Tom
Cruise and Nicole Kidman and all the
[ __ ] that they had to kind of plumb to
play these particular characters and you
know Stanley Kubrick wanted to get like
some verisimilitude in there too because
I heard that he made Tom Cruise and
Nicole Kidman sleep in their characters
bedroom like on the set like while they
were just so they could kind of like get
the whole realism thing going so some
people have speculated that this that
the shooting of this movie kind of like
exacerbated the problems in their
marriage that they already had you know
what I mean because you could kind of
see it like how on screen yeah and I
think that was one criticism that when
this movie first came out that they
didn't seem I mean for a married couple
they didn't seem to have a lot of
chemistry with one another which was one
of the things that I thought when I
first saw the movie but now that I think
about it and now that I've seen it a
bunch more time
I think that makes the movie better
because I think that's kind of the whole
point of the of their relationship in
the movie is that they're so
disconnected from one another you know
he doesn't know what's going on in her
head but he thinks he does it's like you
know and that and just the fact of her
having a fantasy she didn't mean cheetah
she didn't cheat on him she just like
revealed that she had had this really
elaborate fantasy about this stranger
that she saw like the year before and
you know she said I would have you know
if this guy had like said he just wanted
me for one night or something I would
have liked abandoned you and abandoned
our daughter and everything just abandon
my whole life and that like really seems
to shock him and kind of sends him off
on this Odyssey which is interesting
because the the story beats of this and
there's like a lot of like literary
references and [ __ ] like that that's
scattered throughout this um this story
is very reminiscent of the Odyssey like
you know what I mean like with them
going off and like Odysseus going off in
Penelope or whatever her name is
Penelope or whatever back home with all
the suitors and everything like that so
it's paralleling that as well you know
what I'm saying
all right yeah what no I'm just saying
yeah I think it's a stretch I mean it
kind of does but there's a lot it's not
because like that a lot of the
references that he made in it look like
the the creepy Count Chocula dude like
at the beginning who's dancing with his
it was the Cole Kidman at the party that
she's kind of flirting with they he says
something about Ovid it's like there's
all and there's all like you know the
kind of statues in the back and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so there's all this
you know how Stanley Kubrick movie yeah
yeah anything means something and it's
all [ __ ] you know I mean different
layers of it it's just but like you said
I I think it's I like the story but I
think I definitely I definitely think
that that you know the the movie in a
the book that he chose to tell you know
to tell this story it is he is telling
us something I mean this has been going
on and they're in the ruling class for a
long time and they're hiding it that's
what it's all it's about right but I'm
just saying that that's not the only
thats not
really even the main none of the other
stuff it's just that the other stuff
really isn't it's more interpersonal
stuff between this man and woman that
have been married for a long time he's
kind of sick of her but from some weird
reason he's sick of her but he's jealous
that she fantasized about some other
dude so that tempts him to go out and
screw around on replace hookers and
going these weird sex parts he doesn't
do anything either because he's kind of
[ __ ] you know I mean he's a [ __ ] for
not doing it and then he's also a [ __ ]
for getting upset that she fantasized
about this it's cut to me it's it's it's
childish he's that he's a childish
character well some people have pointed
out like I said that the main point of
his character like you said he's very
unlikable and even Tom Cruise said that
that he didn't really enjoy playing the
character because he didn't like the
character but another loss of a woman's
fantasy yeah which and like I said in
the fact that he's been married to this
woman for nine years and he's like
shocked by this revelation yeah that she
also has sexual desires and she also
because the whole point of that I mean
that like I said that whole argument
that they have like when they're both
high that's kind of the instigating you
know incident that like sends him off on
this path which i think is strange just
it's it is but like I said this this
kind of the whole point that he seems to
have never considered because he's
trying to tell and he says this pretty
much word-for-word
that that's not how women think he says
to a woman as though he knows what she
thinks like more but he has like all
these ideas about what women are like
and what women think about and then she
kind of like schools Amit is like no
this happened last year and it's like I
still remember it and she very vividly
remembered it she's like so we're just
as sexual as you are we're just as
interested or allured by sex with
strangers as a man would be and he is
seemingly very shocked by that and I
don't know why because she was just
flirting with two young actresses and
models that were coming on to it from
his point of view that's just what men
do but women aren't layabout yeah like
the one weren't involved that was two
women I know see that so that's kind of
the fact that it's like where he never
even thought to consider that his wife
was like that this is wife was like that
or that women in general were like
that was kind of the whole point of the
story was like him coming to the
realization that he didn't really that
he thought he knew what women were like
and they weren't anything like men and
like finding out that that he was
completely wrong from my point of view
is I just thought that I saw that angle
is kind of amusing and kind of dumb
because I think it's just I just take a
[ __ ] for granted but in your and I'm
being shown a character that from my
point of view is pretty lopsided
although there are guys like that yeah
it's just well they're kind of showing
that he's a little bit naive yeah
exactly because and the interesting
thing about his character - and I didn't
really realize that until this until I
watched it again last night
was that every time he gets drawn into
some encounter like when they're at the
party at the baguette the Ziegler's
party at the beginning and he gets let
off by those two women you want to go to
the end of the rainbow or whatever the
costume shop is also called the under
the rainbow a matter of fact so that's
another mirroring there but so they're
leading him off and he would have gone
with them it seemed like but then like
he came and got interrupted so it's like
every time he goes and like is gonna you
know do the deed like he goes in the sex
worker Domino he goes in her apartment
he's gonna sleep with her probably but
then his wife called so every time he's
always like interrupting so it's almost
kind of like he doesn't have he's very
passive like a siphon he doesn't have
any agents he comes back the next day
and he almost screws the roommate in the
roommate says oh no she's got AIDS yeah
and he he loses his rock ups he's like
oh I can't do this now and so what did
you think sex was all about of course
there's gonna be risk yeah you know man
[ __ ] so it's almost kind of like him
coming to the realization that fantasy
and reality are two different things
yeah or that because like I said it's
kind of like every time he tries to do
something in reality it's like fraught
with danger like he goes to this sex
cult and he gets threatened would they
actually do anything to them we don't
really know because they leave it
ambiguous over whether they killed Nick
nightingale whether they killed that
girl that weren't him I'm pretty sure
they did I mean yeah but I'm just saying
that the whole point is that they leave
it ambiguous yeah so that it could go
either way yeah maybe it was all staged
like Ziegler said it was or maybe it
wasn't you don't you don't know I think
they just I don't think they I think
they just killed her by shooting her up
with a bunch of heroin that's what she
normally did anyway yeah I was deniable
and then the other guy they I don't know
if they killed him but I'm sure they
beat his ass yeah you know cuz they
admitted that he beat his ass
yes or at least like hit him in the face
well that's to be the same as beat yes
yes beat him over you know they beat him
up and then send him away and you know
he wasn't gonna talk because he knew how
powerful and rich those people were yeah
they are talking about stuff like child
Island man and they're a bunch of those
groups there's gotta be well yeah like I
said hi he's telling us about it thank
you then there's then there's the whole
occult aspect to it yeah they use kind
of an Illuminati type before right and
you know it's it's they're just he's
just trying to tell us that there's
secret societies and they've been around
for a long time and you know there have
been ex presidents and presidents that
have mentioned that the United States is
not going to be controlled by secret
societies think one JFK I think said
that and it wasn't wasn't quite really
clear what it was what secret society
was talking about and I think it was
something in the Intelligence Agency do
you remember that speech no yeah it was
JFK said that so there and it's in its
it's an old boy network they've been
around a long time you know what I mean
kind of like that damn creation of care
ceremony well you know I forgot the name
of that thing you know but the big owl
and a big ceremony that they got got it
on film and it's just it's just old boy
networks and clubs and these guys have
money to get away with [ __ ] they're so
rich do you know I mean police can't get
on them yeah but like I said to me that
seems like the least interesting aspect
because everybody knows that that shit's
been going on since time immemorial I
didn't know it and I think a lot of
people didn't believe it until a child
Island man and then you know they
they're powerful enough to kill him he's
in prison you know it's and then
evidently goes back into Europe with you
know royal families and stuff well yeah
like I said I've been doing this kind of
[ __ ] for generations that's what I mean
so I write
generations but um but that's that's the
message of the movie another interesting
thing about it and some people have
pointed out fit may be now there is
something of like a surreal aspect or
maybe a hyper real some sort of aspect
even though this movie is supposed to be
set in New York and they did shoot some
like b-roll footage and stuff like that
in New York they actually you know
Stanley Kubrick was he lived in England
and he was famously afraid to fly so he
wanted to shoot the whole thing in
Britain so they essentially built
Greenwich Village at Pinewood Studios in
London and they also dressed up the some
like streets in London I think in
Kensington and stuff like that to look a
little bit more like New York now some
of the scenes with like Tom Cruise like
walking down the street if you see him
like what what would the one of the guys
that work in the film said if you see
Tom Cruise walking on the street like
from the front in the back that's
rear-projection if you see him walking
from the side down the street then
that's London that's not New York
but like I said a lot of us on a set but
the interesting thing about doing it on
a set is that it gives it like a weird
like fairytale kind of quality where
it's not quite because you can tell that
that's not New York you know what I mean
even though they did try to recreate it
but some people have said because the
original novel which I think was called
tram novel like in German which
translates to a dream story even though
that is talking about the Nicole Kidman
character Alice who I think her name was
Albertina in the book but you know since
her dream or her fantasy was like kind
of de kicking off thing of him going off
on this like weird tangent some people
have also argued that Tom Cruise's whole
journey which is only like two days like
in the universe of the movie was
actually a dream because it mirrors
Nicole Kidman's dream about her getting
like [ __ ] by all the guys and laughing
at her husband you know what I mean so
some people have thought that the whole
[ __ ] that he went through because they
they're they're arguing that like a lot
of it is not
super-realistic some of it is like kind
of over the top or like kind of weird
and like fairytale like so it's almost
kind of like it's a dream or not
necessarily a dream but not really in
reality either like kind of in a weird
liminal space like between like reality
and fiction because some people have
said too that I mean the whole title
Eyes Wide Shut it means you're denying
things like you kind of know what's
going on but you choose to like close
your eyes to them you know what I mean
whether it Oh about it but you won't see
it right whether it's you know not
seeing your you know your wife sexual
desires in the same way that you see
your own sexual desires or whether it's
not seeing you know kind of the
corruption at the heart of like society
and things like that
so it's just kind of like several levels
of it going on you know like I said so
I'm not saying that the movies not you
know it's nominally about the sex cult
but the sex cult is not really the main
focus of it I just think it's like
that's it's like the larger mirror of
the relationship between the two of them
and by extension the relationships in
marriages whether it's blowing the whole
overarching theme is sexual corruption
that's what it's about
yeah about it I mean even then even him
even though he's kind of [ __ ] naive
he's still got a lot of like corruption
and miss his naivete makes him blind to
what's going on he can think led along
as a let along and then he's not it's
just a lot of it it's about the sexual
power dynamic to you know the men but
about the secret cult in society and man
and woman yes it's so it's just you know
kind of like I don't know
[Laughter]
that's mundane problems I don't have
those problems
everyone has problems yeah yeah those
are the problems with people that worry
about [ __ ] like that no I'm just saying
yeah you don't worry about that [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] yeah but it's like it is
something that a lot of people worry
about jealousy infidelity I don't
[ __ ] worry about what some woman
fantasizes of
that's not the same as doing it well
yeah I fantasize about getting pissed
and [ __ ] knocked in somebody's head
somebody's head off and [ __ ] you know I
mean that doesn't that doesn't miss
that's not the same as that's not the
same as doing it yeah you know it's the
same thing but like I said the
interesting family he's awful [ __ ]
sensitive you know that she fantasized
about sleeping with them dudes oh my god
I can't take it and it's like Oh [ __ ]
are everywhere actually I can I actually
read a really interesting piece like it
was two different writers on vulture and
they were arguing that you know not only
was eyes wide shut the best movie of
1999 but also that much like Stanley
Kubrick's original conception for the
film it was actually sort of supposed to
be a dark comedy yeah which I guess I
could kind of see that it's like what I
was reading that and I was kind of like
think about the whole scene where that
dude [ __ ] is jumping on those two
Japanese guys for fooling around with
his daughters yeah I'm gonna call the
cops and then later on you find it was
all set up he was pimping his daughter
out to the two Japanese guys and got a
big sum of money for it and the daughter
was into it
yeah all right that's pretty [ __ ]
corrupt right there that's that's a wild
[ __ ] and the girl is supposed to be
underage yeah is that dark comedy or
what what is that that's what I mean and
and I just like I feel like there was a
lot of comedic moments in it that I
think at the time we're not seen as
comedic and I think they kind of worked
it weren't maybe more like sardonic yeah
I don't think it's too funny I mean dude
[ __ ] pimping out his so it's not
really funny I mean but and it just kind
of added into this [ __ ] theme of
sexual corruption through this whole
yeah that the world is a [ __ ] bad
place and sex money and power is really
running it you know that's that's what
that scene was all about and there was
the whole thing - about I don't even
know I don't know because she knows
Stanley Kubrick his movies are very
layered and very complex and lend
themselves to like a lot of different
interpretations I don't know if he was
necessarily saying that there was safety
I guess in the bonds of matrimony if you
strayed away from that then you
could die you know what I mean because
like he literally like gets threatened
by the calls then he you know didn't
have sex with the prostitute that ended
up being HIV positive and then if you
notice there's like little hints to that
like when that dude is when that dude is
following him down the street and he
stops at the newspaper thing and the
newspaper that he buys which is the New
York Post in big letters like the
headline says lucky to be alive so most
like he just barely avoided because he
didn't stick his dick in anything else
like you barely avoid and of course
that's what it means
yeah that's what that's what it meant
yeah because there's a bunch of threats
out there yeah and I mean the sex cults
and [ __ ] getting trapped in
prostitution stings underage
prostitution stings and getting trapped
with [ __ ] prostitutes with AIDS you
know so yes yeah like in Italy like like
the desire for anonymous sex yes is
dangerous
yeah riddled with pitfalls exactly what
the movie says in the movie does says
you should be thankful that you're
married yeah thankful that you're
married to a beautiful woman and that
you have a family that's what that's
what them that's how the movie ended
yeah because and I think the whole point
the interesting thing too is that one of
the first scenes in the movie which I
think is trying to establish you know
like I said you don't find out until a
little bit later when he's talking to
Nick nightingale at the sanada jazz club
or whatever that they've been married
for nine years but you can see in the
first couple scenes like when they're
getting ready for the Ziegler's
Christmas party you can see he's trying
to establish how familiar they are with
one another one of the first scenes is
them getting ready for the party and
he's like in there looking at his hair
in the mirror and she's like on the
[ __ ] toilet like wiping and [ __ ] like
that is it like in the fancy they're
used to each other right they're used to
each other so I think that's another
thing and it's kind of like an
unaddressed thing between them where
they're just so familiar with one
another maybe they don't even see each
other in a sexual way anymore
well now that was pretty much
established to me because she yeah
things like you're always beautiful it
yeah and he's like not even at her age
he's not even looking at her yeah like
because he's just like used to seeing
her and the fact that and the fact that
he is so alarmed by her you know very
vehemently
retelling of this vivid fantasy that she
had that suggests to me that in all the
nine years they've been married and
however long they knew each other before
that they've never really talked about
their sexual fantasies or anything like
that so like I said they're almost kind
of like even though they're very
familiar with one another they're also
very much disassociated from their own
desires he's very dissociated from her
desires it's like and she has to be like
to be flirtatious to talk about sex when
she does it at the party like for that
Count Chocula she's drunk when she does
it Agilent yeah he was like a Hungarian
did when she does it like to him she's
high like on pot so it's almost kind of
like she has to have her inhibitions
taken away so before she can be honest
with him about her desires and that
alarms him he he accuses her being
aggressive so I was saying that these
are kind of like mundane problems I
don't have normal problems yeah human
[ __ ] normies are like that man you
are [ __ ] freaks all right well yeah
that's to me it's like it was very funny
it was very funny to me how cuz even in
1999 I knew our personal histories and
like that we're like now I'm gonna get
into it this is a movie review but then
like it's also shown in the movie that
not all men and not all people say pay
the same penalties right for doing this
[ __ ] like The Count Chocula god you're
talking about yeah he had nothing to
lose
yeah he could go out and [ __ ] all these
women into it how's that gonna affect
him negative right well yeah and all the
people at the party they just hired
hookers then right yeah you know if they
say what they want matter if he was
married or not he could do whatever he
wanted he had all this money yeah and he
was an older guy in his 50s and he was
still looking pretty sharp and he can
put the move on anybody's wife that
wouldn't matter to him yeah it might
matter to your husband but [ __ ] your
husband yeah he didn't give a [ __ ] about
your husband or you well you know
clearly is about Count Chocula that's
what this is about
which I understand that too it's
interesting there's a little bit there's
a little bit of a class thing too
because even though um you know Tom
Cruise is care
bill is a doctor and him and nicole
kidman I mean she you know she's a
stay-at-home mom but they have like a
really really nice apartment and all
this other stuff they're still like not
on the top echelon of the 1% board was
kind of tacky did you notice that it was
a little bit well actually that was
colors and [ __ ] it's funny because
that's um that was a recreation of
Stanley Kubrick and his wife's yes then
like all the paintings and stuff that
was his wife's paintings am tacky tacky
[ __ ] colors you know I don't like
that kind of color than the house yeah
Watney colors at my house not those kind
of colors though though you know I must
say that during during the 90s that was
a popular color palette yeah it's not so
much that it's like tacky is there was
of the time it was other times yeah but
you know like I said so even the fact
that he was very wealthy he still wasn't
up to that level I mean because that's
why drop his doctor card all time make
sure buddy I know and it's like I had
forgotten about that because it I had
forgotten because I haven't seen this
movie in several years but I had
forgotten what a [ __ ] smug glib prick
he while he was doing that because times
doctor him dudes were [ __ ] trying to
beat him up and call a [ __ ] on the street
remember that yeah so well know if I'm a
doctor he was always like throwing that
down like to get information yeah I
imagine you know what I think I think
they were trying to say that there was a
little bit of insecurity oh yeah he is
massively insecure yeah massively
insecure because [ __ ] you know I mean
average Joe average joe's didn't really
respect him that much he but he had that
damn doctor card yeah and I think that's
what that was all about and another
thing too that kind of hints at the
little class thing is even when they're
at the the Ziegler's party like at the
beginning the Christmas party he got
invited there presumably because I guess
he was Ziggler's doctor or his wife's
doctor or something like that so you
know he was one of his patients or
whatever so um so he gets invited there
but you know him and Nicole Kidman her
dancing and she's like do you know
anyone here and he said not a soul he
doesn't know anybody there the only
person he knew was the working-class guy
the dude playing the piano so the fact
that you know that was the guy that got
him into this party and they immediately
knew that he wasn't of them be
he showed up in a taxi and some of the
password and everything let's talk about
the quality of the movie yes
first off the shittest Kubrick II and
his [ __ ] well yeah a lot of it
especially the cult scenes reminded me a
lot of the shining with with in the Gold
Room and the ghosts yeah he and they
even play that song it yeah that into an
appointment it is telling you that it
it's the same class of people okay
and it there is when you see the cult
there is some kind of supernatural
weirdness to it I mean the singing
sounds like death Dead Can Dance yeah
sounds like dick and dance and the
voices of the chanting don't quite sound
right they sound kind of ghostly did
anything supernatural happen in it no
not that I could tell it it seemed to be
some kind of sex magic cult yeah it was
it to me it's it came across as some
kind of like holy and like it kids like
I said it was basically just a pretty
and a dreary looking orgy and it's like
even the way he's walking through it
like just kind of looking at it like it
was a nature program that 10 to 10 to 13
I've tried to count them because
everything means something Kubrick says
I thought was trying to look for
numerology how many girls there were but
they were kind of these nude sex slaves
and they were slaves evidently they were
kind of owned supposedly and they could
pay for things with their lives and
weird [ __ ] like that
and it's just like you got these 10 to
13 of these tall skinny sex slaves with
these masks on and shoes and they go out
and have sex with people why everybody
else watches and they're all in masks
and these [ __ ] cloaks they're also
having sex with each other and that's
you're not really sure they're just
there to service the crowd I guess you
know maybe they're prostitute to me the
prostitute they said they were yeah but
all they said they were prostitutes
outside of the call well and the one
girl was the same girl that OD that yeah
party but agrees
said they were processed we don't know
that yeah that's just what he said
right they might have been slaves okay
or some kind of cult member a slave like
is slave to a cult it's it's nothing's
proven it's just yeah like I said
everything just like kind of leaves a
damn big yeah so because I don't think
it's supposed to be at the child Island
they were both kind of slaves and
prostitutes they were kind of mixture of
the two they were coming out of these
trailer parks here in Florida and if
someone were brought in under contract
but some I'm stayed there and nobody
knows how many of there were there were
hundreds of them some of them evidently
can't be found where they killed you
nobody knows it's all deniable yes a and
it is it is talking about a similar
situation and in that whether or not
Kubrick knew about it firsthand I don't
know maybe there's several of those or
many of those and it's rumored I don't
know I don't think anybody know nobody's
talking about it depends if more gets
caught or what
also maybe [ __ ] kind of like the nexium
cult maybe like that yeah might be there
might be more of it out there you know
anyway um uh yeah you don't want to talk
about too much about child Island man
they might [ __ ] come and get me I
don't know okay this just seems like
Kubrick knew something he was trying to
tell us the acting in the movie was good
real good is this Tom Cruise his best
work I don't know Magnolia was pretty
[ __ ] good which actually came out the
same year as this there's a couple
scenes where he's covering his face too
much like he can't take it because
there's just too many damn [ __ ] in the
world you know I mean like doing like
this this seems kind of it doesn't seem
genuine yeah seems like it's a little
bit over like you can't be that upset
about this dude
well they bout it though and this is
kind of what this piece that I was
reading that went a little bit into
maybe this is supposed to be like a
little bit sarcastic or a little bit
like of a dark comedy kind of tone yeah
because particularly like at the end
where he comes home and Nicole Kidman is
sleeping and the mask is on the thing
next to like he's busted
and then he just immediately starts
crying and it's like you know I'll tell
you everything and like the over-the-top
way he reacts makes me think that maybe
that was done deliberately you know what
I'm saying so tonally and stylistically
this one you can put it right there of
the shining it's very similar in tone
and feel it is it's not horror not
really I don't even know what genre I'm
gonna notice either because honestly it
was kind of marketed like before it came
out I mean there was a huge marketing
push I think this was actually his
second most financially successful movie
it made like buckets of money but um you
know he had died before it came out so
he didn't get to see that but um but the
Warner Brothers was really pushing this
and they kind of marketed marketed it as
an erotic thriller like they put a lot
of like emphasis on oh it's an orgy and
it's like crazy and all this other kind
of stuff even though I don't feel like
that I think they just kind of used that
as a cheap marketing gimmick and that
wasn't really what the movie was about
like so I don't even know what genre I
would call this it's like a dark
relationship drama with occult overtones
or something I don't even know what I
would call it I think I don't know if
it's necessarily erotic in the sense
that I didn't think any of the girls
were good-looking that well and well in
this sense that I don't think that the
erotic seems like the orgy and stuff I
don't think it was supposed to be
titillating I think it was supposed to
be creepy and unsettling and kind of
showing you that maybe what you thought
you wanted like an like consequence-free
sex with like anonymous people like no
strings attached you know maybe that's
not the best thing
whenever Kubrick shows a nude woman in
these movies that kind of [ __ ] go
back to that woman in the bathtub shine
I know when she was young for a second
real [ __ ] skinny and long looking and
not shapely at all you know what I mean
and that's kinda cool Kidman kind of
looks like that you know she's got a
pretty face and she looks good in
clothes she takes her clothes off there
she no curves you know I mean it's just
like it's like like something out of
Cosmo it's kind of like a gay man's
version of a way a woman should look you
know I'm talking about
a gay man like this I can't ask anyone
seen on American fashion model types
just guys don't really like that build I
don't you know in general you know most
guys are [ __ ] didn't it someone kind
of like a hustler honey you know more
realistic shape booty and you know some
[ __ ] stacked on you know stacked and
not so tall shorter and and all the
[ __ ] women in the cults were like
that - yeah Anakin's tall skinny like I
said I think that's kind of what they
were going for because they were
supposed to be symbols more than people
and then to me I'm just [ __ ]
animalistic with it you know I mean it's
got to look fertile it looks like I want
some Venus of Knightley don't like
getting pregnant if I look at it can't
stare at it too long you might have
pregnant it hate that [ __ ] the cure foul
it's like a mask over your eyes so you
don't accidentally yeah that's how
that's how much estrogen is in there
just on the verge getting press
spontaneous just [ __ ] right yeah
they're kind of short with curves and
boobs shiny and chrome pregnant that's
just that's my taste
yeah I'm just saying that I think that
it was kind of I mean this got I I think
like some critics like really really
loved this when it came out like Robert
Ebert Roger Ebert really really liked it
some some critics thought it was really
disappointing but I think maybe some of
the criticisms that they had were
because of the expectation like I said
the way it was marketed before it came
out and I think because there was so
much you know behind the scenes [ __ ]
going on with you know Tom Cruise and
Nicole Kidman being really married in
real life and like all these rumors
about them coming out like about their
marriage being on the rocks and whatnot
and then about how long the shoot took
and like how everyone was having like
health issues because it was taking so
and I was getting stressed out so it's
kind of like I feel like that might have
marred it somewhat and also the fact
that it being Stanley Kubrick's last
movie because he died like shortly after
finishing it and you know so people had
like certain expectations for it it was
going to be this like his final artistic
statement or something so I think people
were maybe expecting something that
wasn't there or wasn't what he wanted to
make you know what I mean I think people
should have just taken it on its own
terms so I think that since it's you
know been out you know for more than 20
years at this point and I think it's
gotten reassessed where people are more
able to like separate it from the
context of the time that it came out and
are more able to see it for what it was
intended to be rather than what it was
what it was not what it was marketed to
be or what people were expecting it to
be yeah cuz like I said erotic thriller
this is not an erotic thriller I mean
not because when I think erotic thriller
I think that [ __ ] that's like on
skinemax you know what I mean like about
maybe like Basic Instinct or like one of
those Basic Instinct ripoffs or
something you know or like body of
evidence that horrible one with quicken
Madonna with the hot wax don't bother
it's thoughtful I mean won't if I was in
it and I love him but it's like it was
it was a really really bad Donna did not
age well just psychologic raizy and
crazy as she [ __ ] win I liked her
back in the 80s but she just I did as
well I actually can annoy I had a couple
of her albums I think I had a couple of
realms up until true-blue and then after
that I was once you get it's kinda like
Bono you just they just start crawling
up their own asses so much for a mess
well it's just I mean one good when you
get that famous it's really hard to keep
yourself grounded yeah it's like [ __ ]
stayin man so yeah we're sex I stink
stink start talking you like dude man
just shut up please
you're ruining it I still like you for
all my [ __ ] police album I think I
get so listen I just try not to think
it'll boil Dukan [ __ ] yeah I mean
there's only one person that can do that
and it was David Bowie
yeah only David Bowie could act that
[ __ ] I mean David Bowie he jumpity he
was kind of like the only person that
could get away with
he could get away a lot of uh penis and
you know what I mean it's yeah III class
personally knew he was dirty he was bad
well he didn't make any see he didn't
make the secret of it you know so you
knew exactly that's kind of why he got
away with it yeah because it's like he
could be pretentious but he could turn
around and like yes more coke yeah and
like you know kind of like make fun of
his own pretentious yes and it's like
you know you can you can do it then yeah
it's a it's a fine line to walk but we
did not take himself that that serious
that's kind of what he had a good sense
yeah see I think that's that's kind of
the key there is that you can you can be
whatever you're like as long as you
don't take yourself too seriously and
don't get all like if somebody like you
know just you have to have a sense of
humor about yourself man you can't just
get all defensive and it's like should
it mean all right so you'd be like back
to the movie it was good [ __ ]
direction was really good the shots
everything the way it's a beautiful
beautiful good and it's it's man when it
came out
I wasn't all that impressed I wasn't
either I know I put this right next to
the shiny I think it's cool yeah the
shining is a straight-up horror movie
but this is almost adjacent to it
it's a lot like it it felt a lot like it
yeah it has that same like kind of slow
unsettling sort of yeah they go down by
[ __ ] cameras falling I'm down the
hallway just the way it's shot way it
feels it feels a lot like you know
talking to mr. almond a lot and it feels
like a lot of it just it feels like a
little bit of higher class you know so
you talk about people with a little bit
more money but it just it really had
that shining feel to me can I say I love
the use of Christmas lights in this and
I think that is significant also because
pretty much everywhere he goes is like
has this has all these beautiful
Christmas lights and Christmas
decorations like it's like it's this
kind of like really multi-coloured like
warmth and kind of reminding you of the
season all the time the only place that
doesn't have Christmas decorations or a
Christmas tree is the mansion like where
the Sun ever whenever the servants would
show up and give him letters and weird
creepy it's almost kind of like always
dealing with Grady yeah
I mean just and the music and the
parties if it felt like you were dealing
with the same people that damn made the
damn Overlook Hotel yeah and it's
definitely telegraphing it to you that
it's that same class of person that same
type of person
so remember had my theory that maybe the
Overlook Hotel was like a [ __ ] temple
yeah a temple made of evil maybe it was
like yeah xx cults and it was that same
cult yeah that was doing that maybe oh I
want to mention too like there's a
couple more things I wanted to mention
that I forgot I wanted to mention to you
that a lot of people have pointed out
that they think that the main guy like
at the in the sex cult red cloak he's
not give it a name they think that might
be Ziggler yeah it's him because yes
ladies moving the damn ball yeah because
he does that thing with the thing and
then he with the staff and then at the
end when he's talking to Tom Cruise in
the character on the pool table and he
does the bottle that was obvious
yeah so it's yeah I was like in case
anybody didn't notice that yeah also
much like in a David Lynch movie there's
a lot of mirroring of characters in this
like after you know after the whole
argument that they have you know that is
kind of the instigating incident like I
said and as I said every time there's
some kind of like emotional a person
like that it's like Tom Cruise's
character bill is always interrupted by
something it's like somebody shows up or
it's like the phone rings or something
so during this you know altercation that
he's having with his wife or this
argument he's having his wife the phone
rings one of his you know patients has
died and so he wants to go over there
and like you know console the family or
whatever then it turns out that the
daughter of the old dude that's dead
like she's engaged to be married to
somebody else but then she like pledges
her love to him even though they don't
know each other again anonymous sex so
it's almost kind of like they're
mirroring like in this scenario he is
the naval officer that his wife was
fantasizing fantasizing about and the
woman Marianne is Alice because even her
hair is the same color and it's like in
the same style and [ __ ] like that so
everything is like mirrored and then
when her fiance shows up he looks like
Tom
Connie's got the same haircut the same
hair color but he has glasses on like
Alice has so it's like so it's constant
like mirroring of like characters like
from one scene to another and also some
people have said because she's named
Alice like Alice Through the Looking
Glass because there's like a lot of
mirrors and [ __ ] like that
like I said so there's like there's so
many like [ __ ] layers this movie just
like any other [ __ ] Kubrick movie
somebody needs to make a documentary
like they made about the shining room
t37 with all that although most of the
shining theories like obviously it is
layered and he did have like a lot of
there are a lot of hidden meetings in it
but some of the [ __ ] like if faking the
moon landing stuff that's [ __ ] I'll
believe it yeah that's - well it's too
much of a stretch yeah you know I'm
saying but he did have somatic elements
he did have like I said he did mention
in this movie he referenced other movies
and he even like said this later on but
in he was referencing like The Odyssey
like I said he was referencing like some
ancient poems and like with the
paintings and [ __ ] like that in the
background so he was doing that but you
I think that he had a tendency to do
that but I think some people like maybe
will take it a little bit to see it
again your I think the Odyssey thing
yeah you're right while he's off on the
journey all the women [ __ ] trying to
hit up his wimp his woman back back at
the she's back at the homestead
abstention yeah that's there yeah I mean
it's I've seen that reading like
multiple times like various people that
have in my take my take on the whole
cult element is that they weren't
LARPing as a cult I think it was a cult
because it was too organized and I think
they did kill the girl but I think they
getting just gave her a bunch of drugs
yeah and she was probably good she was a
drug addict anyway but why was she drug
addict she had drug out because he just
kept giving her drugs to keep her under
control yeah and there they were hookers
but they were but they were just LARPing
that they were in a cult maybe they were
hookers that were inducted into a cult
yeah yeah I mean and given a bunch of
drugs and taken care of you know I mean
until they became security risks and
they got rid of them so like you said
it's all kind of gray yeah I mean well
the MBAs on how you want to describe and
the ambiguity is
boy and the ambiguity is he is I mean
the character of Bill he's kind of like
he's not privy yes [ __ ] that's going on
in the top you know the question is is
was it a cult or was it people sexual
perverts LARPing that they were in a
call and in the end would really matter
my analysis that it was a real cult yeah
yeah which it very well made yeah I
think it was a real code yeah but yeah
so if you haven't seen Stanley Kubrick's
last film Eyes Wide Shut in a while and
look I even wore my Overlook Hotel shirt
just really Cajun it's the only stay
like uber check you know I have a
Clockwork Orange one too now that I
think about it should have worn that one
[ __ ] I forgot but I haven't worn this
one or a while yeah if you haven't seen
it in a while um you know check it out
again because it really did even though
when I saw it in the theater I liked it
but I was just kind of like a you know
it's not cuz I was like a big you know
yeah Kubrick fan I love it as well but
it did actually aged really well and the
more you see it the more kind of layers
come to the surface and like I said like
all of Kubrick's films this has multiple
interpretation you want to watch the
shining again and it also made me want
to watch a Peter Sellers movie name
being there was also about a secret
society I haven't seen that in so long
and I'd love to like that I don't think
I've seen that since like them get that
on blu-ray if it's if there's a blue
ribbon yeah you should probably order
that [ __ ] I will say that we have we
have the blu-ray of this right if I
swatch oh yeah that you ordered yeah
it's good cop it's got like a bunch of
extras on it but it's weird because I
guess because this was Kubrick's last
film and they're generic and he and he
died like before it was you know before
it came out the the extras that are on
there aren't specifically about this
movie there's like some interviews that
are about with his career as a whole but
yeah and there's some interviews about
Tom Cruise talking about a little bit
yeah my people [ __ ] goof on Tom
because of Scientology in the crazy [ __ ]
that he's [ __ ] said in the past but I
respect huh good actor and he does his
own stunts and he aged pretty well he's
probably how old in this movie maybe
thirty Oh Arnie something and
he's kind of thin but you can see he
really got a lot bigger in the years
after that yeah he buffed out a lot you
know man [ __ ] this is kind of the
last movie you see him where he's not
big yeah he's like he's in good shape
but he's not like not massive not matter
I kind of take that in later and I'm
bigger than him in that movie and we're
about the same size guys we're both
shorties hey man he rides motorcycles
does his own stunts and [ __ ] you know
what I mean and he does he doesn't like
communist [ __ ] does he he does weird
[ __ ] with Scientology whatever bad
whatever whatever well you know what you
gonna do join the army he can't join the
army and do all that kind of stuff he
was a famous actor yeah so he got his
training for Scientology and I think
they get course he got he got the best
Scientology he didn't get and like I
said he didn't get the shitty
Scientology where you had to sleep in
the trailer and poop in a fondo say they
would make they were making whole
compounds for Tom and his wife well yeah
and they made like all the slave
Scientologists [ __ ] make his [ __ ]
vehicles to [ __ ] do ya they had to like
do all the [ __ ] for him it's like hey
plants all these flowers over here like
cuz he likes those and all yeah although
they're gonna call a Scientologist
they're gonna call me like servicemen
[Laughter]
get they've given their time to the
[ __ ] organization to save the earth I
was gonna say like the first time I saw
this movie I think like Tom Cruise's
character like pissed me off a lot but
now that I'm watching it again I'm like
I think that was kind of the whole point
of his character yeah it is
was that he's supposed to be unlikable
he's supposed to be he's not overtly on
like he's not overtly I'm lookin he's a
[ __ ] really like a superficial
[ __ ] Chad yeah he's very superficial
he's very passive he you know he's
easily led by the women he's he's a beta
it's like he's you know when he's
walking down the street like the
prostitute doesn't go up to a prostitute
she comes up to him and it's like hey
then back to my apartment it takes me
forever to realize that this is a
process it no he knows it's a prostitute
nasty man yeah I don't think he saw it
coming up first he just was like nah
maybe he did so go play you want to have
fun oh you wanna have fun yeah where
yeah yeah what yeah he so he's just kind
of eczema he just ends up being led
around by his dick essentially but then
he never but anyway this is pretty
constantly blue balls behave yeah he's
always getting interrupted or he always
like changes like oh this is this is
unwholesome poor talk last night this is
carrot yeah horse control the earth and
it's like she didn't even do anything
else it was like think about it yeah
having to go out to try to get us a real
poo nanny nanny
isn't that with you naughty but they had
to call it Poonani is this Steven
Seagal's word for it who died I don't
even like to say that it makes it
socially when I think about Steven
Seagal saying it out loud go it's an
amazing man if they remake this movie
they should put Steven Seagal at em
please magically I'm throwing him from
baby I can body double for every [ __ ]
shot yes don't even come in eventually
Steven Seagal movies will just be his
eyes everything else is until the eyes
then eventually it's just eyes with
glasses women be hilarious if they've
just made a straight-to-dvd which I
guess they are nowadays but a Steven
Seagal movie and it's just like an hour
and 45 minutes of Steven Seagal and then
he can't show up to the shoot so I have
another dude there with glasses over the
eyes like you can't tell intent there's
even there's even Steven Seagal movies
where it's not even his voice yeah
it's somebody else's voice trying to
hello Steven Seagal like I said why do
you think I have to turn up there just
like it was just say in your trailer we
don't we just start making the movie
yeah call me when the checks come in
it's time to shoot your seat
kiss somebody else do it yeah I'm kind
of busy right I got a dream my energy
all right so uh as usual we went up we
were talking about Eyes Wide Shut but
yeah so check that movie again what does
everybody else think about it this is
kind of a one of his more I guess it's
more of Stanley Kubrick's more not
controversial but like in the sense that
it tends to get more mixed reviews than
some of his other ones so I'm kind of
curious what everybody thinks about it I
liked it I liked it too like I said I
don't it's it's not my favorite movie of
his by a long stretch but it's not bad
but I appreciate it a lot more than I
did when I first saw it you know what I
mean so so if you haven't seen it well
then check it out once again